if you're looking for ways to stop
making excuses love yourself and think
critically then this video is for you
self-love is not an indulgence it's not
a nice-to-have
it is a prerequisite even if all you
want to do is feel successful even the
person in the with the broken heart the
person who's down on their knees whether
they see it or not they have a choice to
rise above their circumstances you need
to learn to think because thinking makes
you act effectively in the world
thinking makes you win the battles you
undertake what sup believe nation it
seven my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have an
amazing gift inside you that I want to
see explode out into the world now I
started to believe life series to try to
tackle some more personal development
topics on the weekend to help you become
the best version of you so let's live
our best believe life and learn today
the five steps to becoming a better you
enjoy
[Music]
the concept of improving lives runs
through the center of everything I do
and then I realize that the the way to
improve lives is to continually improve
yourself right so with that every every
morning when I when I get out of the bed
you know I I haven't fixed everything in
the world yet so there's always
something to do and in this film I read
an interesting quote the Siddhartha
Gautama the Buddha he said that good
people have to get out of the bed every
day and try to empty the ocean with a
ladle right and I thought that was you
know I knew that was profound and I
paused for a second and I said all right
what the hell is a ladle right right so
there you know I just I touched it on my
iPad is ladle oh it's like a big spoon a
big spoon okay so try to empty the ocean
with a soup spoon you know as the the
mentality of how you you wake up every
day to try to do good in the world so
for me I'm I'm really driven by
continually trying to elevate my elevate
my mind and elevate my spirit and care
for my body and to be able to love as
many people as effectively as as
possible with this mystery of life that
I've been given
I realized I'd say two years ago but
especially in the last six months very
recent that and this is the part that
would make my Tim of five years ago just
Crane like vomit a little in his own
mouth much of this I'm not gonna mince
words I still have trouble sayings like
self-love is not an indulgence it's not
a nice to have it is a prerequisite even
if all you want to do is feel successful
and take care of the people you love the
most to really take care of them you
have to as I've heard said put on your
oxygen mask first mm-hmm and if you
don't do that like you you are also
shortchanging your ability to care for
other people completely and that that's
been a very very much an hundred and
eighty degree about-face for me right
because for a long time I was like I
don't need to care for myself mmm like
that's the word keeps going back to me
which is self-indulgent like this is
self-indulgent mink who cares I came
home one night from work spraying for
cockroaches and long story short I turn
on the Discovery Channel and I saw some
guys going through Navy SEAL training
and they're going through hell week and
they're getting their ass just beat you
know in out of the water
guys ringing the bell there was
suffering and I was waiting like 297
pounds and I had to make a change in my
life you know I was at all-time low and
I wasn't going anywhere and I was
exactly what everybody said I was going
to be which was nothing so I had to make
a change what was it about seeing
suffering that's that's really
interesting and actually get it but I
want to hear you explain it why
suffering was the thing that triggered
that thought well for me growing up I
came from a horrible background I got
called [ __ ] every day of my life
growing up lived in a small town the
Klan headquarters at that time was about
20 minutes from where I lived the one of
the high ups in the KKK son sat behind
me in two classes so you called me [ __ ]
a long time got my first car they spray
print [ __ ] we're going to kill you on
it so I was just an insecure scared kid
and the only way I could find myself was
to put myself through the worst thing
possible because I'm gonna say the exact
opposite of what the world today's world
is saying so we read a bunch of books
nowadays as humans we we want to find
out how to be someone else what we don't
do is we don't go inside so literally
turn yourself inside out read the book
that says like we're writing a book
every day of our lives
but we never read that book every day
we're seeing who we are as people when I
was growing up I I lied for people to
accept me because I did accept myself so
I would make up stories so you so then
you would accept me into your world I
would uh everything I did was for
someone else to like me it was until I
started reading my own book about how
pathetic I was as human being I could
blame my dad I can blame kids at school
I could blame having health issues ATD
my mom not being around great mom but
she was doing her thing I could blame a
lot of people and that's the book I was
reading and I put it off on everybody
else it was until I say you know what
for me to fix this I gotta read what the
hell what the [ __ ] is wrong with David
Goggin not blame anybody read my books
okay I'm afraid of my shadow how can I
overcome that going in military get your
ass kicked
do things you hate to do be
uncomfortable every day of your life
Roger that
I'm not the smartest kid in the world
okay it says somebody saying oh no
you're smart no no I don't say that to
yourself
I said to myself no I'm a dumb okay
Roger that how you get smarter educate
yourself so the things that we run from
we run it from the truth we're running
from the truth man
so the only way I became successful
was going towards the truth as painful
and as brutal as it is it changed me it
allowed me to become in my own right Who
I am today I was in Johannesburg a
little while ago and I went through the
the airport and I went into the men's
room or washer room or bathroom however
you want to call it and so I walked in
to the men's room and the first thing I
hear is welcome to my office
and this was the janitor at the
Johannesburg men's room that's funny
hoo-hoo janitor eyes door I'll make up a
word cleaned the men's the toilets like
Mozart composed music now that man has
no money that man probably has very
little education that man is judged by
the world as having an unimportant job
and that man is a hero could be here two
millions of people why because he
actually saw himself as an ambassador to
South Africa and his passion was was
palpable and his visceral commitment to
doing work at the highest level was like
you don't see even from the CEOs and all
I'm saying is even the person in the
with the broken heart the person who's
down on their knees whether they see it
or not they have a choice to rise above
their circumstances and leadership and
humanity is a testament to the people
who have done it I mean you read read
the group you look at Mandela you know
27 years in imprisonment when his son
died he wasn't allowed to attend the
funeral of his own son he said that was
the one of the great pains of his own of
his life and what did he do the victim
looks at something like that torture and
says I am broken and they give up and
they spend that they closed their heart
they closed their mind they closed their
creativity and they blame the rest of
their life on what happened to them but
Mandela what he chose to do was to use
it as an opportunity because actually
the things that break your heart if you
choose can open your heart and fear the
world says fear is bad fear is only an
opportunity for
every training and what he did was he
used those 27 years of torture to open
his himself mentally physically
emotionally and spiritually to the point
where when he was released and became
the president of South Africa he invited
his jailers to sit in the front row at
his inauguration and he was asked why
and he said because if I don't I'm still
gonna I'd still be in prison and that's
a long way of saying but you know we do
make excuses because we are very good at
self-deception because if we actually
had to face the responsibility of
playing with our bigness in the world
we'd have to let go of our addiction to
our excuses and and leave what's safe am
I making sense really no you're talking
that you don't have to leave what's safe
I mean we are addicted to crisis
sometimes it makes no sense we are
addicted to pain and we'd have to
actually leave the pain to go out to the
possibility of pleasure and joy and
greatness and believe it or not that
frightens us right so we make these
excuses and then we blame people Oh Jo
or Robin I don't like the way he looks I
he he speaks differently but
subconsciously as you're suggesting
those are just our protective mechanisms
to avoid owning the responsibility of
our brilliance the best thing you can do
is teach people to write because there's
no difference between that and thinking
and one of the things that just blows me
away about universities is that no one
ever tells students why they should
write something it's like well you have
to do this assignment well why are you
writing well you need the grade it's
like no you need to learn to think
because thinking makes you act
effectively in the world thinking makes
you win the battles you undertake and
those could be battles for good things
if you can think and speak and write you
are absolutely deadly nothing can get in
your way so that's where you learn to
write it's like when I can't believe
that people aren't just told that it's
it's it's like it's the most powerful
weapon you can possibly provide someone
with and I mean I know lots of people
who have been staggeringly successful
and watched them throughout my life I
mean those people you don't want to have
an argument with them they'll just slash
you into pieces and then not in a
malevolent way it's like if you're gonna
your point and they're gonna make their
point you better have your points
organized because otherwise you are
gonna look like and be an absolute idiot
you are not going to get anywhere and if
you can formulate your arguments
coherently and make a presentation if
you can speak to people if you can lay
out a proposal god people give you money
they give you opportunities you have
influence very first thing I do when I
wake up in the morning is I want to get
my head right I do this thing called
priming now some people get up in the
morning and they meditate and I think
meditation is wonderful but I haven't
met many people that can not think
thoughts this is a different outcome
this is about priming yourself it's
about putting yourself in the state
where your mind and body will respond
accordingly we all do three steps it's
really simple over 10 minutes so why
don't you sit down I'll guide you
through it so just get really
comfortable I want to be sitting up is
that back enough for you to be able to
relax yeah good okay cool and then the
first thing you gonna do is your hands
are gonna come up as you take the breath
in and then you're gonna explode out the
nose down explosive that's it good
that's it keep going two more good now
relax keep your eyes closed
hope you four hands open if you would on
your lap face up like that just feel
whatever you feel just take it in you
don't have to respond to me anymore you
just enjoy it take it in and now just
let your body relax deeply and I'd like
you to begin to think of a moment of
your life you could feel really grateful
for if you wanted to it could be
something little richer it could be
something big it doesn't matter it could
be from your childhood or this week it
doesn't matter
do your best to remember it and then
step into it as if you were there kind
of like stepping in your body and seeing
what you saw then through your own eyes
hearing what you heard then feeling what
you felt then
savor it
maximize that sense of appreciation or
enjoyment or gratitude
enjoy it feel it fill up with it and now
we're gonna ship to the last piece
really simple all you're gonna do is
focus on three things one at a time that
you want to accomplish three things you
want to achieve live it and feel it and
experience it
I was not
yeah what you feel yeah yeah there's two
worlds the master the external in the
internal world they both have to be
bastard but if you act match to the
external world you know Allah you know
Robin Williams but you don't master the
internal world there's a big price this
is the one to master first and so I
start my day by making that so I have
this base to do it I'm gonna live from
gratitude today I'm gonna live from
blessing you know I'm gonna be a
blessing people's life today I'm gonna
get stronger today and I'm gonna achieve
what I'm here committed to do and the
whole thing you know we did that one in
the less than 10 minutes to give you an
idea
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
did you learn from this video that
you're going to immediately apply
somehow to your life let me know down in
the comments below whose advice
resonated the most with you that you're
gonna spark a change please let me know
it'd mean a lot to me I also want to
give a quick shout out to Mike from
restaurant HR Mike thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my new book the top
10 roots a success I really appreciate
it Maine and I'm so glad you enjoyed the
book and had the desire that posted on
Twitter means a lot man so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is
much love I'll see you soon
so it all comes down to this basic
question that human beings have for a
long long time being concerned about
transforming their minds is there any
way in which one's mind can be
transformed or is it simply a process
which is nothing more than a vicious
circle
I could ask why have you come here this
afternoon what were you looking for
would it be too presumptuous of me to
say that you were looking for help that
you hoped you would hear somebody who
had something to say that would be of
help and relevance to you as members of
a world which is running into the most
intense difficulty the world beset by a
complex of problems any one of which
would be bad enough but when you add
together all the great political social
and ecological problems with which we
are faced they are appalling
and one naturally says the reason why we
are in such a mess is not simply that we
have Ronald systems for doing things
whether they be technological political
or religious but we have the wrong
people the systems may be all right but
they are in the wrong hands because we
are all in various ways self-seeking
lacking in wisdom lacking in Courage
afraid of death afraid of pain unwilling
really to cooperate with others
unwilling to be open to others and we
all think that's too bad it's me that's
wrong and if only I could be the right
person is this man going to tell me
something that will help me to change
myself so that I will be a more creative
and cooperative member of the human race
I would like to improve let's look at
this thing from another point of view
which you will first think highly
depressing that's supposing we can't do
anything to change ourselves suppose
we're stuck with it now that is the the
worst thing an American audience can
hear there's no way of improving
yourself because every kind of culture
in this country is dedicated to
self-improvement so here's the situation
you see there is no that the the whole
idea of self-improvement is a is a will
of the wisp and a hoax that's not what
it's about let's begin where we are what
happens if you know if you know beyond
any shadow of doubt that there is
nothing you can do to be better well
it's kind of a relief isn't it seeing
that there isn't really anything we can
do to improve ourselves or to improve
the world if we realize that that is so
it gives us a breather
in the course of which we may simply
watch what is going on watch what
happens nobody ever does this you know
and therefore it sounds terribly simple
it sounds so simple that is almost looks
as if it isn't worth doing but ever just
watched watch what's happening and watch
what you are doing by way of reaction to
it just watch it happen and don't be in
a hurry to think you know what it is you
think this is the material world
well that's some of this philosophical
idea now maybe your you think it's
spiritual
that too is somebody's philosophical
idea this real world is not spiritual it
is not a material the real world is
simply
[Music]
so could we look at things in that one
thing without as it were fixing labels
and names and gradations and judgments
on everything but watch what happens
watch what we do now if you do that you
do at least give yourself a chance and
it may be that when you are in this way
free from busybody myths and being how
to improve everything
your own nature will begin to take care
of itself because you're not getting in
the way of yourself over time you will
begin to find out that the great things
that you do are really happening
woodsy ones were long yeah the most
important work ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you Apple so it would be
like a little beacon they believe nation
if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details
[Music]